d'un avis général on en parlant avec
tous les amis influenceurs journalistes
ce qui ressort c'est que dans l'ensemble
des smartphones avec incroyable qui a
été présenté dernièrement c'est à dire
soit à peine 10 jours
le mexique c'est quand même ça
[Musique]
pour la saint jean est né à barcelone
derniers jours pour moi ici à barcelone
le salon s'est terminée mwc fini très
gros salon est la grosse tendance va y
avait deux grosses tendances pour être
vrai la première c'est effectivement la
5g fidji ici on l'a vu marquer partout
alors la 5g on va en parler très très
rapidement parce que j'ai eu la chance
d'être invité par qualcomm au mwc donc
j'étais très près j'étais à des
conférences tables rondes pour parler de
5 g et j'ai appris plein de choses et ça
je vais vous le dire pour vous puissiez
réellement apprécié ce qu'est la 5g vous
allez voir c'est bien plus que ce qu'on
peut croire et le deuxième gros truc je
dirais c'est enfin ce sont les écrans
pillages alors c'est quand payable on en
parle beaucoup on a parlé du smartphone
pliable de huawei il ya quelques jours
on a parlé la semaine dernière du
smartphone pliable 2 samsung et j'en ai
vu d'autres et y en avait d'autres
d'autres produits ça c'est intéressant
ça demande beaucoup de sauts dont ce que
je vous propose c'est on retourne
directement au mwc mais juste avant
c'est à profiter des joies barcelonaise
je n'ai jamais changé d'hôtel pas si
vous avez suivi d'un autre hôtel la très
sympathique aussi regarder je vais faire
un peu trop j'aime bien les petits tours
les hôtels comme ça on en plein centre
de barcelone ça nous était très
sympathique
alors bon j'étais seul pas de potes avec
moi mais ça c'est cool c'est cosy c'est
mignon comme tout regardez-moi ça comme
on est bien là alors regardez je vous
emmène visiter faire dix tours vous
allez voir un temps fou à barcelone
hyper appréciable et là on est hyper
centrale regardez-moi s'enflamme à la si
vous regardez au bout
je joue un peu la balle assez les
ramblas tout au fond vue incroyable sur
la rue commerçante
on est pas mal sa vie s'écoule et si
vous connaissez ya la place royale qui
est par là sur le côté et maintenant
c'est un petit tour du côté du mwc
auprès des grands clubs vous allez voir
on n'est pas au bout de nos surprises
on est dans le stand de tcl
juste là derrière et là vous avez je
pense que c'est leur partenaire est le
faire dès qu'un écran c'est à vérifier
si s aux petits et ils nous montrent
l'état claude écran alors on va
effectivement des écrans du parfum
d'écrans oled et ils nous montrent
également un écran cliquable ça c'est
assez intéressant alors on voit que ce
n'est pas un smartphone c'est pas un
produit abouti mais ce qu'on voit c'est
que c'est un écran pliable en actions
qui se piquent dans un sens puis dans
l'autre et tout ça mélangé au milieu
d'autres écrans ce que ça montre ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est la
démocratisation toute douce des écrans
pliables
on y arrive davantage pour l'instant je
pense que les produits sont pas encore
complètement finalisé c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont tous sous cloche qu'on n'y a
pas accès qu'on peut pas les prendre en
main ça va arriver
de toute façon il était très clair qu'
il y avait des effets d'annoncé en 2018
on a su que huawei allez sentir sur
smartphones écrans pliables que samsung
allait faire samsung le sait depuis très
longtemps
huawei également forcément ne serait ce
que pour avoir la recherche et
développement
donc c'était à qui sortira son
smartphone à écran pliable premier sauf
qu'en réalité aujourd'hui ils sont pas
prêts et je pense c'est encore un peu de
boulot pour qu'ils puissent être
complètement fini commercialisable avec
ça intéresse du monde donc c'est pour ça
que je pense qu'ici il ya eu les effets
d'annoncé mais ils sont encore tous sous
cloche
bon il faudra du temps avant tout cas ce
qu'on est très intéressant c'est que ça
va arriver ça arrive tout doucement on
pourra probablement très prochainement
les prendre en main donc cette affaire
une seule ça vous abonner comme ça on en
reparlera ensemble dans les 62 tcl alors
on a pu voir tout à l'heure les écrans
les techno en tout cas le niveau de
leurs fournisseurs d'écrans voir quelle
manière ça se plier dans un sens d'un
autre intéressante est la variable il ya
leur proto le smartphone s'appelle le
dragon inn chasse un smartphone à écran
pliable qui devrait sortir en 2020 alors
j'ai quelques infos là dessus c'est un
smartphone avec un tag onale de 7,2
pouces amoled bien évidemment avec
une résolution de 2048 par 1536 pixels
un écran qui va occuper 90,73 bon sens
de la face avant
et oui messieurs dames on a globalement
très peu d'information là dessus on voit
en tout cas que l'idée là c'était de
montrer un peu le proto parce que de
toute façon tout le monde sort son
smartphone tout le monde commence à
montrer la france marque rona écran
pliable et ce convoi était très
intéressant et ils le disent 2020 on
voit que les patrons des campings sont
montrés commence en tout cas être
aperçus tout le monde y va de sa copie
mais très clairement avant 2020 il va
rien à voir devient dingue au niveau du
grand public
[Musique]
dans la famille des smartphones à écran
pliable je veux le matrix de huawei est
tombée alors c'est que paris s'y
retrouver un jeu cas pas de logo merde
hélas ici alors le smartphone est caché
là juste là alors j'étais à la presse
deux jours intéressants
je pense que si elle constate le plus
abouti à des plis l'objectif est sale
j'aurais pu me le dire quand même là ça
va mieux comme ça donne l'avis général
en en parlant avec tous les amis les
influenceurs journalistes ce qui ressort
c'est que dans l'ensemble des
smartphones avec aprilia qui a été
présenté dernièrement c'est à dire soit
à peine 10 jours
le mythique c'est quand même celui
qu'elle est faible plus le waouh ça
c'est plutôt cool
on comprend bien le côté usages en fait
du smartphone et on voit bien ce qui
nous apporte compact grand écran pas mal
maintenant la frustration ce pas avoir
pu le prendre en main et il y en a qui
ont pu mais sur des temps très courts
alors un smartphone comme ça il faudrait
l'utilisait suffisamment longtemps pour
pouvoir réellement se rendre compte des
apports moi je trouve ça cool on est au
début on est au début
[Musique]
juste là vous avez le fold de samsung
alors ils ont vraiment optimisé le truc
hein on ne peut absolument pas le
photographier ni le film et dans des
conditions intéressantes
il ya des reflets de lumière de tous les
côtés y fait franchement horrible très
compliqué alors c'est le smartphone qui
va être lui pour moi le local à la
présentation est la plus lourd
tout est décevante
c'est un peu compliqué parce que on
l'attendait depuis longtemps samsung a
annoncé dès 2011 travailler sur
smartphone avec un écran pliable alors
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de recherche
et développement ça prend du temps à
venir mais là on a un truc comprends pas
trop en fait à l'intérieur vous avez une
énorme encoches avec les deux appareils
vous avez une patinoire sur le côté
c'est que c'est gros et d'autant plus
que samsung n'a jamais fait une encoche
sur ce smartphone pourquoi sur un
produit comme ça sur un produit aussi
conceptuel ils mettent une énorme
encoches ça c'est difficile à comprendre
on est loin de la goutte que vous avez
sur le sort le s10 plus là je ne
comprends pas ça ce serait un peu de mal
et à l'avant vous avez un tout petit
écran jusqu'à 4,5 pouces alors que tout
une grande partie qui n'est pas utilisé
alors c'est assez compréhensible
d'autant plus que sur la pub qui a
tourné ou qui tourne encore il vous
présente ce que seront les technologies
du futur les innovations selon samsung
et on voit très clairement un smartphone
avec camping avec un très grand écran
bord à bord hyper sexy et du coup on
vous vend du rêve et là vous avez un
truc qui a annoncé ok j'ai difficilement
compréhensible donc est ce que c'est un
proto est ce qu il devait sortir
maintenant parce que tous allaient
sortir peut-être qu est ce qui va
arriver à l'avenir
c'est ça ce sera plus sexy que ça parce
que si c'est ça mon avis ils vont
vraiment se manger les dons
[Musique]
il ya de la famille smartphone pia vous
avez un truc qui vient de l'espace c'est
regarder ça la rend pas très bien c'est
energizer alors que j'adore vous
connaissez les piles et là ils nous
sortent un smartphone à écran pliable
alors c'est la garder alors ça je pense
que pour l'instant c'est qu'un proto
c'est hallucinant deux en un fonds table
est ok grands ouverts de 8,1 pouces
format 4/3 fhd plus s'il vous plaît
fermez 6 pouces 18/9 fhd plus également
on a trois appareils photo à l'arrière
48 plus 12 mégapixels à l'avant 24 mai à
105 g compatible double sim
seul un dragon 855 8 gigas de ram 256 go
de stockage extensible jusqu'à 256 go de
stockage et une batterie de 10000
millions paire eur rien que ça et une
recharge rapide en usb type c'est bien
évidemment alors ça je sais pas si ça va
sortir quand on pas comment ça semble
être vraiment
concept
tronche qui a un pouce au don est un peu
rayé ah oui la traînée celui-là bon en
tout cas même si c'est probablement pas
le le produit qui va être l'effet waouh
là on voit que tout le monde s'y met un
peu et même des acteurs comme une
ambiance assez diverses preuves et en
plus être sorti un smartphone massif
si vous mettez dans votre poche c'est
que vous avez des baggy parce que jean
c'est impossible avec une batterie de
18000 milliampères heures alors
j'imagine même pas combien de temps vous
allez le garder sans le recharger sûr
mais c'est juste voilà histoire de faire
parler de la marque parce que c'est
strictement impossible d'utiliser un
produit comme ça c'est beaucoup trop
massif voilà pour ces écrans pliables or
on va reparler très très très
prochainement il ya plein de choses à
dire dessus une grosse actu va y avoir
beaucoup d'annoncés a priori au nord
pour arriver dessus aussi en 2020 tous
les acteurs vont y arriver petit à petit
c'est vraiment hyper intéressante et moi
ce que vous en pensez vous est-ce que
les smartphones à écran pliable c'est un
truc qui vous botte est ce que vous
voyez l'intérêt oui non et puis quelle
copine vous plaît de plus vous invite à
me marquer tout sans vos commentaires et
puis rester connecté abonnez-vous et
visionner la playlist qui s'affiche par
ici comme ça vous aurez toutes les actus
et toutes les nouveautés
john w c est bien plus encore vous
embrasse à bientôt ciao